madame monsieur bonsoir toujours latente
à beyrouth la tente mais aussi une
certaine détente le docteur rad a
interrompu ce matin ses négociations
avec les ravisseurs qui détiennent
toujours les otages français
c'est apparemment à la fin de la
première phase des discussions avec une
indication une indication de l'émissaire
français
un accord de principe est en voie
d'élaboration mais il reste encore à
régler les détails des détails qui
semblent importants une note optimiste
donc ce soir même si les inconnues
demeurent très nombreuses
nous allons revoir point par point
l'état de la négociation mais d'abord le
film de cette journée à beyrouth avec
notre envoyé spécial c'est pire ces
rumeurs sont disons encourageant les
deux choses différentes et réseaux
toutes concordantes
aujourd'hui être sur la bonne voie
les conditions posées par les ravisseurs
sont virtuellement rennie dirait qu'elle
est réalisée s'est donné 48 heures le dr
à des navettes entre beyrouth banlieue
sud et tomates pour être au point les
bonnes été pratiquée garantie d effet la
décision de libérer l'équipe quand elle
a été prise sow sort des paliers l
affaire de bagdad dit aussi des
solutions que les affaires pourraient
être pourtant concomitante ses
coéquipiers devraient être libérés au
plus tard reconnu
vous l'avez entendu optimisme donc
optimisme mesuré sur place mais il faut
rester très prudent l'expérience dans
cette affaire nous l'a appris à de
nombreuses reprises en tout cas il
apparaît à peu près certain ce soir que
le docteur rade à négocier sur deux
points au moins la libération des deux
opposants irakiens expulsés par paris et
le sort du commando qui avait tenté
d'assassiner le premier ministre iranien
à paris le premier ministre chapour
bakhtiar le premier point est actif ce
soir mais le deuxième reste à régler
daniel leconte la remise de de nos
frères irakiens aux autorités irakiennes
alors que la france savait qu'ils
étaient des opposants régime
et qu'il serait exécuté en irak est un
défi dangereux au sentiment de tous les
musulmans
ceci constitue une complicité de crimes
c'est dans ce communiqué annonçant la
mort de michel seurat et publie il y a
une semaine à beyrouth que le djihad
islamique évoqué pour la première fois
la question des deux irakiens expulsés
par paris depuis dans chaque communiqué
publié par la suite leur libération est
devenue la plus urgente des
revendications des ravisseurs
c'est donc maintenant chose faite la
libération d'amanda phase i et d'hassan
géraldine n'est plus qu'une question de
jours sinon d'heures saddam hussein le
président irakien en effet gracié les
deux expulsés ils sont autorisés s'ils
le veulent à retourner en france
un préalable capital pesant sur la
négociation vient donc d'être relevé
reste maintenant
l'autre revendication des ravisseurs
elle concerne la libération de cinq
membres d'un commando communiste ces
cinq hommes avaient tenté d'assassiner
l'ancien premier ministre iranien
chapour bakhtiar
c'était en juillet 1981 à neuilly au
cours de la fusillade deux personnes
devaient trouver la mort
arrêté sur le champ quatre d'entre eux
dont le chef du commando anis naccache
été condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
le cinquième à 20 ans rien juridiquement
ne permet de le libérer dans les
prochains jours
les cinq hommes n'ont accompli que six
ans de prison or la peine minimum qu'ils
doivent obligatoirement purgé de 15 ans
pour les en 15 ans pour les uns dix ans
pour l'autre on est donc bien loin du
compte
reste donc une seule solution pour
répondre aux ravisseurs la grâce
présidentielle
et puis